hello everybody my name in mark bar huh
ah you didn't see oh you didn't see guy
you didn't see you don't know you don't
know cuz girl and I burn I'm going to
wah wah ha if it happens again I'm gonna
be softer I'm never gonna tell you what
it is but if it happens again
got my fessed up Samuels ass ok the
story Bing it all started Oh about an
hour ago when I was trying to get this
other game to work and it did not work
and I was upset
uh I got a little rabbit are you feeling
better
no [ __ ] you promise I'll explain
god no don't die I must ask if eaten can
you purify your auric hydroxide of gold
no you can use the equipment in the
bedrooms when you come back I have
something to show you guys anything
there guys ok ok so it all started I'll
try to get this other game to work and
it would not work no matter what I tried
so I had to contact the developer about
that to try to get that came to work
I decided photo stressful I'll relax
which tell me amnesia
ah yes puzzle I mean I took organic
chemistry in in in college I took it an
accelerated course and I did well but to
see it in amnesia and then there's that
weird glass breaking I don't know what
that is that happened before and I'm
just angry and now I'm in a bad mood I
got bad things running through my head
I'm on destroy everything I see ah
and I just want to woo I'm under
I'm so mad I'm show
aren't we bubbly angry but it's okay I'm
gonna calm down because I'm gonna do
this correctly this time I'm gonna do it
nice and calmly whoo okay so basically
what we've got here is in the bedrooms
we've got a chemistry set and with this
chemistry set there's some lab equipment
that we need to use a very explicit and
careful manner oh look here let's see
hmm can't turn the burner on I probably
need to put my Arak hydroxide in of
which I have to for some reason so let's
put that in there oh now I can heat it
up
so let's gently heat the material to
875,000 degrees and then up can't
combine it when it's still heating got
to be very even on the heating so take
the reactant and then insert it and then
the reactant mix successfully and what
do you have you have Arak hydroxide
precipitate precipitate and then this is
where I got stuck because I have no idea
what the hell I'm supposed to do I put
it back in for some reason I put it back
in and I still have some so this is
uncharted territory I don't know what's
going on here what right I don't know I
don't know I don't know so there's
something there that's gonna be boiling
so I'm like ah see I might be done here
I don't know what else to do
hmm wells I guess I'm out of oh no I'm
not what's in here ah let's see here I
it would be better to prepare everything
first well prepare everything well what
do I need to prepare
I can't you shot
I can't use it that way but we can use
that not that way can use this this way
nope
aha we did something can we light it up
no there's where we got stuck before and
then there's nothing there's a whole lot
of nothing in there and I think I may
have kind of given myself a good way to
go because now I actually have something
in here and I might be able to pull in
again
nope no no no no no no why would I be
able to do that oh it's got to go away
isn't it okay so I got that can't use
that item this way that just disappeared
so now I'm exactly where I was before
I have nothing I've got nowhere to go
haha nothing yeah nothing
who got nothing again who got nothing
nothing and then I lost my mind and then
I raged and then okay okay so let's
think about this logically
I put the only solution that I made into
here and I can't do anything else into
here there's absolutely nothing that I
could do with this in any way there is
nothing there is no way to do anything I
can't even turn this lever
what I'm going to do is very calmly and
collectively ah okay all right
now I've been trying I've been trying
I've been trying to throw everything
everywhere it's just a few seconds ago
there very calmly just took my gosh
tournament oh right on the table and it
landed there why I don't know okay I'm
okay
okay so can I do this okay and so
beautiful beautiful thing are Girija
what the hell what the heck - perfect
oh no oh no I thought I had our
courageous where's the gold
ah come on
Oh [ __ ] oh boy Oh I will I will
break your up [ __ ] it
you know what I've had it up to here
with your [ __ ] [ __ ] oh wow
[ __ ] you you're not
[ __ ] I'm gonna good wah I'm gonna kill
you dead you shut up ow
God you stick you so tough you dig
you're so tough I will bust your nipples
off with your friggin chair so angry I'm
higher up to here and that's very high
hi hello hi there can't climb up on this
bed Kenya well back you anyway I'm
running I'm a running
ah ha ha ha
I'm out still bearing chased it's
suddenly very dark in here let me take
some of my love down and do all right
now everything's better but it's much
darker so I was there anything that I
need to do with the Thackery's yeah
oh hi what the hell
where'd you come from [ __ ] got here
it's light in here you didn't see
anything I'll board it up with this Hey
you'll never find me in here the closet
where I've hid so many times before
hello
okay what's going on there oh no I
interrupt him at I interrupted him as he
was bashing down the door yes was I not
supposed to do that
oh yes ah piss ah piss Oh No hello yep i
barricaded this door but there is
another way into the foyer thank you the
for yah the for yay can I use this item
this way aha okay now finally we're back
in moving forward sorry about all the
anger I just have a lot of pent-up
frustration today I'm gonna grudge gonna
okay I'm okay I'm okay so long as that
guy you guys here I'm okay Hey
okay all right so let's get back into
the game
so something diabolical has happened
obviously let me crank the hang on the
brain is just a bit too high let's get
it back into the atmospheric mode whoo
okay little more atmospheric good turn
the volume up - been a bit too quiet
this whole time
whoo now I can hear it that is good
that's new music - it's really cool it's
like every single level that this guy's
made and even though they've been upset
with illusio whole organic chemistry
been I'm not going to be that upset
anymore because I'm gonna get into the
game and we're gonna have scary fun
times
[ __ ] man those guys are everywhere
wonder when the new monsters are gonna
pop out someone told me that chapter 2
is what is gonna happen [ __ ] there's no
hiding place in here oh this can't see
me here get out of here you [ __ ] okay
all right
gonna find a way to sneak around him
where is he I hear him I don't see him I
hear him I do not see him it sounds like
he's all around me what the hell is this
guy where is this guy
where is he I do not see him oh he must
be in this room no where is he Wow oil
finally Jesus I mean this game maker ISM
oh you didn't hear anything I didn't
even know where you are okay last week I
met my new colleagues for the first time
with the inclusion of mr. Bell mr.
hockey mr Boyle we've assembled the
great collection of mindset represent
every major with science within the
circle we're all very excited to begin
sharing our correspondence a great deal
thanks to John and Johan as their
contacts were invaluable in finding
members from my group the inclusion of
Theodore Hawk has given us some an
opening to extend the grain lines of
France as I am aware of his fluency in
French his contact should provide a
great deal of scientific and mechanical
expertise regarding lay okay blah blah
blah scientific blah blah blah Johan
this is no important game information
there I'm gonna get the hell out of here
you didn't hear anything buddy you
didn't hear anything okay I seem to just
I don't know where that guy is it sounds
like he's all over the place okay Jesus
he's not invisible is he ah okay making
my way downtown
whoa oh oh I the big statue hey buddy
whoa I can move you aha
what good is that to me what sighs I
tried to get this oh [ __ ]
how am I supposed to get this guy oh boy
I'm probably supposed to get this guy to
fault Jam you [ __ ] heavy man lose
some weight you skinny bastard
oh god I'm pretty sure this was supposed
to work a lot more eloquently elegantly
oh man he's not moving he not moving
hooking come on oh man jeez your big fat
ass get over there I'm pretty sure I
supposed to tilt this much more
effectively okay go go go go go go go go
now I don't know what that did woo hey
buddy
ah where where boga oh they're down
below me oh ha hum who that I'm not
going down there ha ha ha oh I was
supposed to smash him I don't know maybe
he seems to be stuck there so I'm gonna
go around I'm so I'm so I'll get some
loud down at him ah hello baby
Sammy sorry babe good God
fudge I'm not gonna use any oil [ __ ]
that Oh balls is a dead end
I'll lose you in this one haha ah [ __ ]
what was the point of the foot who was a
point about just call the monsters Jesus
oh they're all over me they're all over
me
okay where are you I I still haven't
seen one of them besides him spinning in
a circle down below
more oil yeah they just sound like
they're everywhere ah [ __ ]
Oh piss oh hey hey boy come over here
come here I got something to tell you
whoops
[ __ ] off can't see can't see can't see
Kensie Oh
another dead end good good good love
dead ends anything here for me Oh piss
he is persistent hey I miss me oh yeah
here get out of here
Jesus baloney holy Maroni the guy is all
over me ah place is not locked off this
ah close it close it close it down it
saw me in here so here more oil all
right
oh man judge as US rice go oh ah God guy
give up [ __ ] out run large large boot
the Buddha
got about a buck hahaha
god damn head guy he would not quit no
matter what man did the maker this game
alter the AI cuz man he was freakin
persistent I don't even know holy hell
oh man this has been the most
interesting episode of ever and I'm not
even part way through the game so man
okay I'm out of time so thank you guys
so much for watching oh man it's like
the greatest amnesia custom story ever
besides the race I experienced earlier
yeah
this isn't fantastic so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye appreciate that yeah it's good
night
duh mother Clark that didn't hurt at all
God such a badass just need a rub my
neck for a pic oh hello I get to bite
you alright shoot the yellow oh damn Oh